so sind stuhlgang textur und was ist das
denn und promis wie eine schlafstätte
ist das schnitzel soße dieses riecht
eigentlich lecker aber und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut wir können
uns eigentlich direkt hinsetzen
das lustige ist immer wenn ich diesen
tisch jetzt immer benutzte oder dann
benutze ich dann wieder drei tage nicht
mehr dann ist er wieder staucht auf
jetzt nur zum pakete aus brücken
eigentlich auf den optional gibt es
immer montags mittwochs und freitags im
video dann habe ich wochenende ansonsten
kommen die ganzen videos auf einem
anderen kanal alex v alle auf jeden fall
vielleicht abonnieren der mann fiel
etwas vor was ich sehr viel mal wieder
gewinn schreiben und zwar erstens videos
ich habe so viele kommentare kommen alex
ankommen dann bitte mal wieder essen des
videos letzte woche kam auch schon heinz
ich weiß aber heute machen wir noch eins
und zwar so ein bisschen back to do
aber damals schon eine menge restaurants
getestet mit der schlechtesten bewertung
wenn man nicht wirklich hingefahren und
auch hin und wieder schon restaurants
von lieferando und ich habe mir gedacht
das könnte man eigentlich mal wieder ein
bisschen einführen bisschen mehr machen
und heute habe ich bock auf deutsches
essen weswegen wir heute mal beim
schlechtesten deutschen restaurant auf
die für andere stelle ich muss dazu
sagen der youtuber sturm waffel den ich
auch sehr sympathisch finde da hat das
auch öfter gemacht deswegen gehen der
papst auf jeden fall raus ich dachte mir
nur wir haben ja auch ein bisschen
anderes liefergebiet und ich denke da
spricht nichts gegen das auch noch mal
so einzig führen auch wenn ich weiß dass
ich selber schon ganz oft bei
lieferanten wegen durch videos gemacht
haben oder überlebt doch deswegen wollte
ich das hier noch mal kurz anmerken
chaplin gerne mal ab da gibt es ganz
ganz viele leute während ich hier runter
scrollen und das restaurant sowie haben
das auch schon mindestbestellwert 13
möchte auch was haben dann können sicher
gar nicht folge leisten könnt ihr super
gerne auch mal kommentieren was dann als
nächstes dran kommen soll bei bewohner
hier in köln und hier gibt es so viele
restaurants also schnitzel feiere ich
schon der sind von diesen videos ist es
ja dann auch am ende immer in der
bewertung zu schreiben meist um das
ganze so ein bisschen zu pushen oder
halt nicht wir haben hier 3,0 sterne und
ich habe bei google auf gesehen haben
sich sehr viele leuchten
über beschwert haben kurz nach 16 uhr
für 17 05 40 bestellt als km und ca 38
in der portion pommes zum schnitzel
waren gefüllt mit zehn kommen ist für
den preis geschmacklich nicht zu
empfehlen zu teuer bestellt mal nicht da
ist wirklich megawatt so saucen sind
stuhlgang textur und was ist das denn
wissen wie eine schlacht schicken wird
gewährt dann noch eine unerträgliche
wartezeit ich dachte man hunger hat
schmeckt einmal sz live und bei google
ist auch nur schlechte rezensionen also
bei google hut zu bringen irgendwie 1,8
oder so deswegen nehmen wir das jetzt
auch du bist doch offenbar schnitzel
oder 1,4 ich mir gedacht ich komm' weiß
so schönes deutsches essen müssen wir
natürlich direkt eine currywurst ihn mit
dem bedarf currywurst mit pommes und
salat so in den warenkorb was ich mich
frage
hier steht überall schnitzel milano
spitzels die neue art wird zu jeder art
und dann steht immer darunter mit
frischen champignons oder irgendwie
sowas aber da steht nirgendwo mit pommes
also sind bei dem schnitzel dann keine
profis dabei oder wie soll ich das jetzt
verstehen das geht doch nicht nehmen wir
einfach mal hier kommt das mag ich dann
gerne im rahmen des zentralen so dass
schon lecker oder das bestellen am 8 12
euro 95 mit ketchup oder mayonnaise 50
cent extra 12 euro steuer 19 ist ein
gutes schnitzel deshalb say vom schwein
weil es so dafür ist das echt zu teuer
muss man sagen das einzige was sie jetzt
noch zusätzlich haben sind so guten
stakes feiert gar nicht deswegen
bestelle ich das auch nicht und das
war's dann auch schon wäre jetzt eine
currywurst und schnitzel also zwei
wirklich deutsche sachen die haben nicht
so viel auswahl mit pommes jeweils dazu
mit salat also es ist schon eine menge
essen was wir jetzt bestellen nur für
mich ich hoffe mal das schmeckt aber ich
muss sagen ich habe ja auch schon ein
schlechtes gefühl wenn dazu eine
schlechte bewertung ist und du hast
meckern will ich ich bestelle es mal
eben und und dann schauen wir mal wie
lange es dauert weil sich viele kunden
ja über die lieferzeit beschwert haben
okay vielen dank für deine bestellung
wie
seit ungefähr 55 minuten das heißt wer
mit 17 und 12 es sollte nach einem
mathematischen verstand um sieben
minuten nach 63 mal deutscher chef ist
schon da so leute essen ist angekommen
ich habe eben noch überlegt ob es
interessant wäre während man halt auf
das essen mache oder meinetwegen auch
schon davor zu diesem restaurant oder wo
deshalb produziert wird in welcher ecke
auch immer vom kelso hinzufahren und das
macht also wenn ihr sagt alex macht es
auf jeden fall mal schreibt die
kommentare aufwendig nicht ganz weiß ob
man das darf aber kinga schon irgendwie
also wir haben jetzt einmal glaube ich
die currywurst und wir haben hier das
schnitzel und wir haben hier pommes und
wir haben hier sogar den salat
falls man ja das essen kam sogar zehn
minuten früher an als gedacht also vom
liefern hat aber überhaupt keine
probleme ich mache das jetzt mal auf wir
können als erstes sehen
ist das schnitzel so es riecht
eigentlich lecker aber das ist ja
irgendwie ertränkt und soße oder komm
ich nehme was man hier raus kommen und
die soße ist schon so daran fest ja gut
das auge ist in dem fall nicht mit
aber vielleicht schmeckt ja vielleicht
ja doch überall
wie hast du das so nur in den
kommentaren chili darstellt nicht so an
oder so aber ich kann dagegen nichts
machen
das ist halt einfach bei mir so dass
wenn der erste eindruck vom essen dann
ist das einfach bei mir wird die pommes
sind aber einfach schön post guck mal
hier
obwohl das gilt wie hat er bezeichnet
den schwanz wir probieren erstmal die
pommes also sie sind schon ein bisschen
lang muss man sagen bewertung von 1 bis
10 6 lief gemeinte sechs punkte es sind
jetzt nicht die mega com ist aber ist
okay so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
probier mal das schnitzel muss sagen das
muss ja eigentlich schön dünn seien
nutzlos günther safe der gar nicht
wissen was richtig drin sein
es geht und das wird zu sagen was willst
du experten nichts neues
[Musik]
was habe ich nicht verstanden das
nächste das lag aber die hatten ja auch
schnellste taxi dann muss er das nicht
für gut sein oder
mein persönlicher geschmack ist das ist
immer ein bisschen dünner ab sein kann
aber es ist okay so ich sage mal so ich
habe schon bessere schnitzel gegessen
aber das ist nicht schlecht
also hier würde ich mehr als drei sterne
geben vielleicht bekomme ich zu dieser
currywurst kommen dass man einmal in den
salat reinschauen und deshalb kann man
was los ist und salat besonders ist
natürlich der ist aber auch nicht
besonders aber einen kommentar war dass
der salat schon so ein bisschen veraltet
geschmeckt hat oder so mega trocken
es geht aber eigentlich also ich finde
da sieht frisch aus neuerdings bin ich
auch wirklich ein großer salat fan
geworden früher habe ich nie salat zu
einem essen gegessen
[Musik]
kann man sich auf jeden fall nicht
sterben ich meine frisch so ist
eigentlich lies auch hier würde ich eine
gute bewertung geben eigentlich sogar
das beste und das meistern ist ist auch
noch ein pluspunkt war wunder also dass
auch vollkommen in ordnung
bis jetzt war alles wirklich sehr gut
aussah wie passt diese ein bisschen
labbrig jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was
uns hier erwartet
hier ist die currywurst mit schöne
currywurst okay also sechs euro 90 für
sowas ja ist natürlich teurer als wenn
es jetzt irgendwie im stadion oder
sowohl ist aber so ein bisschen märz das
ist ein bisschen mehr und das sieht
wirklich gut aus
die pommes inhalt schmecken halt
wirklich gespannt wie schmeckt denn die
soße bisher das wichtigste weil die so
ist es gut
aber auch diese kommen ist hier extrem
lambrich koma das machen wir immer große
komik hier dann kann man natürlich sehen
oder weil ich halt noch liegt natürlich
auch am liefern aber die saucen von der
currywurst ich mir auch wenn ich
eigentlich gar nicht so der currywurst
mensch bin
die soße die geht da muss ich noch mal
ne pommes rein halten dann kommt mir
manchmal die currywurst ich denke auch
die wird mir schmecken sehr hart also
hin zu muss ich sagen so sind unter
currywurst mit pommes in ordnung
bisschen dadurch die currywurst feier
ich nicht also die ist mir zu hart und
die schmeckt irgendwie nicht also nicht
so nah ist das schnitzel ist auf jeden
fall besser im großen ganzen bin ich
aber was der erste ein oder angeht
zufrieden mit dem restaurant deswegen
ist es gleich eine gute bewertung
schreibe also mindestens vier sterne für
das essen fünf sterne für die lieferung
ich kann allerdings gut verstehen dass
wenn leute noch länger darauf warten und
die polster noch ruhiger sind dass man
dann halt auch mal zwei oder drei sterne
gibt weiß ich nicht auf jeden fall mein
geschmack hat an sich getroffen ich habe
natürlich schon viele bessere sachen
gegessen aber auch schon vieles was
schlechter war in meiner lieferando
karriere
deswegen schreibt irgendwann in die
kommentare was für rüstung als nächstes
dran sind also welche nationalität
sätzen lagen
dann machen wir das wenn die bottroper
abonniert den kanal last um nachum da
und wir sehen uns dann am mittwoch
wieder und 19 uhr gibt es ein heftiges
video hört rein
[Musik]